sur l'envoi merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france déjà une réaction
par rapport à la manifestation
d'aujourd'hui et comment elles se
déroulent de toute façon dès qu'il ya
usage un prêt de violences en tous cas
d'actifs ça complique toujours le
message parce que c'est les images qui
vont rester donc l'intérêt pour tout le
monde aussi bien pour les manifestants
les policiers les riverains c'est que ça
se déroule dans le calme comme ça ça
peut forcer le débat de fond plutôt
qu'on se dévissent ur de la forme débat
de fond c'est donc cette loi sécurité a
global notamment cet article 24
quelle est votre position la position
n'a pas changé depuis le début c'est que
c'est une loi inutile qui étouffe les
lois qui existent déjà
inutile dans le sens de la protection
des libertés individuelles et même des
policiers pour le moment si on veut
filmer quelqu'un pour lui nuire et qu'on
diffuse son image sur les réseaux
sociaux
c'est du harcèlement c'est déjà deux ans
de prison si jamais on le menace ces
trois ans de prison et des menaces de
mort qui jusqu'à cinq ans de prison mais
en 2019 nous avons une collègue à
versailles qui a été suivie
photographier jusque chez elle par une
militante qui voulait lui nuire
ben là pris l'année dernière 17 mois de
prison ferme donc mieux que ce que
prévoit la loi aujourd'hui c'est à dire
12 mois maximum donc dit qu'à ce moment
là si ça ne sert pas à protéger les
policiers et les citoyens ça ne sert
qu'à limiter la liberté de la presse est
d'ailleurs encore un gouvernement tous
les cas les députés jean monsieur
castaner doit faire une tribune pour
dire ce n'est pas du tout sens ce n'est
pas ce qu'on a voulu dire qu'on doit
s'expliquer sur les raisons de sa loi ça
commence à être compliquée donc nous
sommes contre cette loi qui met tout le
monde dans la rue les policiers ont
d'autres choses à faire que d'encadrer
des manifestations donc si les députés
et gouvernement faisait convenablement
son travail dans l'intérêt général
on pourra se concentrer sur nos vraies
missions et quels sont aujourd'hui vos
vraies missions
si vous voulez voir avec vous quelles
sont vos revendications est ce que vous
les vraies missions oui belle et vraie
mission c'est de lutter contre le crime
les délits etc
je repense aux propos du préfet de
police de marseille qui depuis a été
limogé qui disait en est content à
marseille les gens ont tous leur
attestation de sortie sauf les dealers
non un dealer on le présentait la
justice aujourd'hui il ya un contexte
entité au risque est très élevé les crs
et de différentes unités sont employés
en renfort sur ces domaines là donc il
ya beaucoup beaucoup de sujets qui
nécessitent les interventions de la
police la lutte contre le crime organisé
la drogue la sécurité tout simplement
des rues pour la tranquillité publique
donc tout ça c'est l'émission priorité
normal après des revendications bien sûr
qu'on en a dérobé des questions pour les
policiers pour une meilleure
considération d'autres travaillent une
prise en charge de politique pour donner
un sens à nos métiers et nos missions je
rappelle que nous avons toujours plus
d'un suicide par mois avec la seule
mesure de monsieur darmanin a été de
mettre en place un numéro vert
aujourd'hui également si une reprise en
main aussi des syndicats qui sont les
porte parole du gouvernement je pense
particulièrement à unité sgp qui a fait
une grille une une grève des contrôles
d'identité etc en disant voilà on va
être gentil ou alliance qui distribue
des bonbons on n'est pas là pour choisir
si on veut appliquer la loi ou pas on
l'appliqué il n'y a pas de sanction du
ministre et à côté de ça également je
pense à ce qui s'est passé à nantes
cette semaine des policiers ont
manifesté de façon la plus illégal
possible ils ont obtenu le limogeage du
directeur départemental en deux jours
après quelle crédibilité on a si nous
policiers pour agir sur des
manifestations qui ont été interdits de
parole préfectorale il faut que la
police soit exemplaire et
malheureusement la tête de la police
n'est pas exemplaire ce qui fait que sur
le terrain nous avons des ordres
complètement aberrant donc voilà de la
cohérence des gens respectables et donc
sur les responsables comme monsieur
l'allemand aux différents directeurs qui
font n'importe quoi depuis un moment
soit limogé
monsieur longueur on parle beaucoup qui
vient de confiance entre la police et
une certaine partie de la population ce
que vous pensez qu actuellement il est
rompu ce bien une fois de plus son
anglais le débat était faussée parce
qu'on a posé les mauvaises questions
aujourd'hui on pose la question aux gens
est ce que vous êtes tour contre la
police en fonction de l'image que vous
avez en tête au moment où vous pose la
question des policiers qui tabasse
messieurs les clubs vous serez contre la
police
et si jamais par exemple c'est nos
collègues qui ont permis d'éviter des
attentats vous serez pour la police la
vraie question c'est quelle police on
veut en fait à quoi elle doit servir
donc en fait le lien de confiance n'est
pas rompu il est rompu avec une certaine
police mais pas toute la police et
aujourd'hui on est dans une guerre de
l'image avec le ministère le ministère
qui les oppose et michel becker tabassé
par des policiers qui ont fait n'importe
quoi
ap un policier qui a été lâché par des
manifestants il ya quinze jours à paris
en fait les deux souffrances les deux
violences sont tout à fait inadmissibles
toutes les violences doivent être
condamnés il n'y a pas une guerre de
savoir qui c'est qui va souffrir le plus
donc à partir de là oui il ya un lien de
confiance qui est rompu avec une
certaines parties de la population se
compose les mauvaises questions mettant
vous posez la question à la population
est ce que vous êtes pour que les
policiers vous protège des actes
terroristes vous permettre de circuler
tranquillement dans la rue encadre les
manifestations pour vous puissiez vous
exprimer
la réponse sera bien évidemment oui et
vous posez la question à n'importe qui
mais vaut plus profit qu est-ce que vous
soutenez les exactions commis par
certains policiers
la réponse sera non donc posant les
bonnes questions recentrant le débat et
à ce moment là la police n'a pas être
aimé ou pas la police a est utilisé pour
faire respecter la loi et aujourd'hui on
a l'impression qu'on est là pour
réprimer le délit d'opinion qui n'y a
encore pas dans le code pénal bien
heureusement